police in haiti say two haitian
americans and more than 20 colombians
are behind the assassination of
president jovenel muis
colombia's government says early
investigations suggest that some of the
men involved were retired members of its
military
moise was shot dead during a raid at his
home on wednesday
some of the suspects have been
identified but officials are still
looking for at least eight others
paddy culhane reports
[Music]
a very public display in port-au-prince
police load two men into the bed of a
pickup truck
saying they may be a part of the armed
gang that allegedly assassinated
president jovanelle mauis later paraded
in front of the press
outside of the police station where
several suspects are being held
an angry crowd gathered demanding the
suspects be turned over to them
those guys killed the president we are
going to make them suffer now that the
police have found them and taken them to
jail
we want them to burn today the haitian
police chief said that 28 attackers have
been identified
26 colombians and two americans of
haitian descent
he said eight were still on the run and
three had been killed
and in a surprising turn the colombian
defense minister
acknowledged some of the suspects had
been in the colombian army
in response to the assassination of the
haitian president
today interpol has officially requested
information
from the colombian government and the
national police
about the alleged perpetrators of this
act
initially the information indicates they
are colombian citizens
retired members of the national army
we've given instructions by the national
government to our police and the army
to collaborate in the investigation to
clarify these facts
immediately our public force is fully
at the disposition of the sister
republic of haiti
this is all unfolding among a political
backdrop of confusion about who is
actually in charge
well first i would say that it is still
it is our view and we continue to call
for
elections to happen this year and we
believe they should proceed
we know that free and fair elections
will facilitate a peaceful transfer of
power to a newly elected
president and we certainly continue to
support haiti's democratic institutions
moise had been ruling by decree after
the majority of parliament
was dissolved in january last year now
both claude joseph and ariel henry
both senior politicians claim they are
in charge
haiti a desperately poor country where
the coronavirus is spreading
violence is surging and political
uncertainty rules the day
and now an international mystery of who
assassinated the 53-year-old president
and why patty culhane al jazeera
washington